i i don't know how many interviews i've
done on this show chris in the seven
years right or my entire career it's
gotta be up enough
one thousands it's it's it's tons of
them very few very few make me nervous
i'm very nervous i can't i can't tell
you how nervous i am right now
because you know how it works in
baseball you don't talk about you don't
talk about this stuff don't talk about
stuff i remember i remember
talk to the person i remember i remember
paul o'neil
in the world series in which he was
raking against the met said just don't
talk about my numbers i'll interview
and then the interviewer first thing the
interview said was you're you're seven
for your last 12 and
o'neil almost walked away you don't talk
about numbers
and certainly these types of numbers but
uh i couldn't be more
uh pleased to have this gentleman on the
show because he is a national story
at the uh prep level
uh because this left-hander or uconn
commit one of the top prospects
in major league baseball a senior at
manchester connecticut's east catholic
high school
has thrown four straight no hitters has
not given up a hit since
april 26th and tomorrow he takes the
bump
to make it five in a row and he says yes
to us
asking him to come on to talk about it
seventeen-year-old frank mohsicado
of east catholic high here on the rich
island show how are you frank
i'm doing good how are you thank you for
having me no no please
rich first of all frank please i'm
nervous my mother will kill me
no it's okay don't worry tell your mom
no big deal i've
you can call me rich that's fine i'm
nervous frank i'm nervous about this
interview
thank you for having me well you're
welcome number one uh why did you say
yes
um you know this is an awesome
experience and uh kind of something you
can't turn down you know so uh okay
you know just how to do it okay you know
i'm super thankful for you having me no
you bet so um why are you so locked in
right now frank
with what's going on in your world um
you know it's easy to pitch when you
know the defense behind you know is
going to make all the plays and
you know my catcher we've been working
on we've been working with each other
since freshman year so
it's really easy to throw strikes and
just kind of do my thing and
you know i don't really really focus on
not giving up a hit kind of just
happened so uh
it's not really a goal of mine so well
frank you've struck out 101
uh batters over your last 42 innings you
sure your defense isn't falling asleep
what place are they making they're
always on their toes um balls do
balls do uh put in play so uh they make
all the plays and
super easy you know knowing they're
gonna make the play so just throw a
strike so who's your guy that you've
grown up that you emulate who's that
player who's that guy
for you oh i'm a yankee fan so i have to
say andy pettit
look at you what are you look at you
you're 17. when do you when do you ever
see andy pettit play
come on what do you got youtube what
have you seen andy
um you know yeah i've seen like clips of
him on youtube but also you know growing
up watching you know him jeter
uh mariano and uh cory basada so uh when
i was a little younger but
you know always try to emulate his pick
off move and uh didn't work out too well
but
well you still have time but pettit
that's a great a that's a great guy
what a competitor frank i mean what a
competitor certainly from the left side
that you're dealing
have you uh you know who have you been
talking to
anybody at that that level that you've
picked their brain or your coaches uh
introduce you to any of these people or
that's still to come for you frank
um that's still to come uh in the off
season i've worked with a couple minor
league
players uh thomas gerrard out of duke he
plays for the orioles now i worked in
the offseason with him
and he kind of just gave me a gist of
you know what like big league ball is
like and uh
he's such a good like person and mentor
to me so when'd you first pick up a ball
where you realized this is
something i might be able to do when's
the first time you did that frank
um i don't i don't know i mean i've
always wanted to do it growing up i've
always wanted to be a professional
baseball player but uh
kind of kicked into me you know after
like my first or second start this
spring that okay maybe you know it's
getting realer as you know the season's
going on so
okay what's it like to throw four
straight no hitters
what's it like you know it's pretty
mind-blowing to me still um
i don't you know the thing is i don't go
out obviously and try and throw a
no-hitter so uh
when it just after like the second one i
throw i'm like okay someone's gonna get
a hit now i'm just gonna happen who
cares you know
out there and do the best i can to get
the team to win but uh
you know after four it's just kind of
like kind of crazy and kind of like
unreal so it's been a cool experience is
that your attitude who cares
is that i mean because i mean no i
didn't and i i wanted
well you know the more you think about
something you know the more you're
you're gonna stress about it so like i
just go out there and give my team the
best chance to win no one i i'm going
out there and like
saying like okay i need to throw a
no-hitter it's kind of selfish so i
can't
can't have that mindset well there is an
eye on mosicato right frank come on
there's an eye and i say that as this
guy is there's an iron rich and eisen
but no the reason why i wanted to follow
up on that is you know
uh you sometimes hear or yeah no big
deal whatever that that it might be
viewed as not
caring um and i just wanted to so
you know your competitive spirit and
fire where where do you get that from
where do you get that from frank um you
know definitely you know playing
backyard basketball and baseball
football with my older brother who's at
central right now
they're actually in the college world
series so playing with him uh
you know in the backyard always wanted
to be beat him in whatever we're doing
and you know never would but
um just that competitive spirit and you
know my dad was an athlete growing up as
well so uh
kind of probably got a lot of that from
him too how many scouts have been
showing up lately
for you frank um the last three or four
games there's
like 45 or 50. that's a lot
that's pretty cool that has got to be
pretty cool good for you man
thank you thank you for you and you're
smart enough to be a yankee fan
good for you yeah there's no met fans in
your household
none of them no met fans they're all
yankee fans okay and
manchester is where where is exactly
manchester in
in the nutmeg state where is that it's
like central connecticut so it's like
pretty much right in the middle and i
live um north of it in ellington
about like 25 30 minutes north in
ellington i spent seven years in bristol
so i know the area um but yeah i also
know central connecticut you might you
some might lean towards the red sox
side of things so you're smart i like
you frankie yeah
i like your life you're welcome i'll
click that one okay uh
so last one for you um i i just
i i i've never asked anybody who i've
interviewed to sign a liability waiver
but um i'm wondering if you know you
could
verbally release this from any liability
if you
if you don't pitch a no-hitter tomorrow
frank is there a way
for you to do that yeah i think it would
be all your guys fault
guilty as charged i'm freaking out frank
you're much calmer than i am right now
man
i'm just gonna go out there and you know
it's states now so like every team out
here is good and
you know they'll probably get a hit so
it's whatever you know
streaks gotta come to an end and um i
don't really care about it that much so
uh
if it happens it happens if it doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't and if
it doesn't then we'll take credit for it
that's the way it goes in the media i'm
trying to i'm trying to teach you how
it's going to work as you move forward
frank congratulations uh on everything
that's happened
uh with you and what you have created
for yourself
uh congratulations on that so much for
having me as well i really appreciate it
let's do this let's keep doing it let's
keep doing it awesome sounds good you
take care of yourself frank
thank you you too thank you you got
that's frank from zacato
right here in the rich eisen show i like
that kid i know
i like him del tufo's getting to know
him right there
yeah i just said dale goodbye everybody
i mean it's like a jewish goodbye right
there but two pyzons talking right
that's kind of it's
it's basically like a jewish goodbye yes
when two italians from the east coast
talk to each other
i'm freaking out over here guys i get it
but it's so cool
that is awesome he's like someone's
going to get a hit you know whatever
that is a great attitude and i'll tell
you what all this attention he's gotten
he's climbing
the prep rankings in 2021 what do you
got for me on that he is the 51st ranked
prospect
heading into the mlb draft that's coming
up and here's something i've never read
um well let's you know when i was
covering
andy pettit in the world series my god
um that he uh has
he's gotten an uptick in velocity and a
curveball that already rates a
60 on the 6080 scouting
scale yeah that's good in case people
want to know but i mean like the old
spin right
according to a scouting report too has
the best chance to be the uh
top pitcher from connecticut since carl
pavano
well charlie morton also from uh the
nutmegs well you know
i don't know if um if frank knows of his
yankee fandom that carl pavano pitched
so few games for the yankees yeah that
the new york post
nicknamed him american idol i-d-l-e
that's what they nicknamed carl pavano
didn't he end up making because of his
contract
like a million dollars a start or
something yeah sort of like steve trout
back in the day
who i believe was a lefty
oh god i've never refreshed mlb.com
for prep results more like i'm gonna do
tomorrow hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here